all right I am Bren King through the HL
collective so I'm [ __ ] 99 yeah so
question [ __ ] 99 is a mixture between
soccer hockey and pinball yeah after the
game is to shoot the ball and put it in
the other team's goal the controls are
really simple it's just pretty much to
button this is just left stick and the
right button on the switch we just
wanted to make a game that you know you
can pick up and play and pretty much
play well play a co-op yeah it's update
players we want to make sure that even
if you had a big a big part you can
still get a lot of your friends - gasps
well so we can also catch the joy colony
already here we do we have a choice here
so I got like oh you ready already
exactly
Jax hold it down from the screen
right now
right back
[Music]
failing miserably
I just wish
after that
waiting for
which is crazy madam
oh man this which is great
every situation
so pretty much biggest right up
they have charged shot
name's go away
legacy
take it back
[Music]
without now
Oh
yes it's out now and it's 999 exact
exact everyone thank you so much
appreciate